aoc claims that the justices misled the
senate she she goes even further she
says the justices lied
if we allow
supreme court nominees to lie under
earth under oath and secure lifetime
appointments to the highest court of the
land and then issue
issue without basis if you read these
opinions issue without basis rulings
that deeply undermine the human and
civil rights of
of the of the majority of americans
we must see that through there must be
consequences for
such a deeply destabilizing action and
hostile takeover of our democratic
institutions to allow that to stand is
to allow it to happen and what makes it
particularly dangerous is that it sends
a blaring a signal to all future
nominees that they can now lie to duly
elected members of the united states
senate in order to secure supreme court
uh nomin confirmations and and and seats
on the supreme court there is so much
that is funny in that babble that she
just spewed out there she's to allow
that to stand is to allow that
to happen
and if and you can tell she's just rich
if if if you read the decision and in
the and to say the things and the
decision that frankly without basis no
she doesn't cite any examples of course
because i highly doubt she has even read
the decision because it's over 200 pages
and there aren't pictures
you know it's not a coloring book so she
hasn't hasn't probably made it through
we went through the decision on friday
when i did my bonus show because it's an
extraordinarily interesting opinion
you've got the opinion of the court
which is they're going to uphold the
pro-life law and they're going to
overrule roe versus wade and casey and
they say that this the constitution
doesn't say anything about an abortion
and so it goes back to the states you've
got the
roberts concurring opinion which says
we're going to uphold the pro-life law
but we're not i wish we weren't going to
overrule rowan casey you've got
kavanaugh who says we're not hold the
pro-life law we're going to overrule
rowan casey we are not going to make any
decisions about abortion so kavanaugh is
agreeing entirely with the opinion of
the court but he's going even further to
aoc's point she says that this
represents a takeover of our democratic
institutions kavanaugh says exactly the
opposite he says no no we are expanding
democracy here we are not taking
anything we are giving away a power that
the court illegitimately usurped in 1973
to make a decision on abortion we have
no decision on abortion we are we are
only sending this back to the people and
the people's representatives then you
had justice thomas's concurrence
which was the best part of the entire
opinion as far as i'm concerned at least
in terms of its legal logic which
pointed out that actually
although the court is is trying to make
a big point of how
the the reasoning in this case is not
going to threaten
cases like griswold cases like lawrence
v texas cases like obergefell cases on
condoms on gay sex on gay marriage on
all of these rights that were discovered
somewhere in the constitution who knew
there was a right to condoms in the
constitution probably not probably not
james madison probably not the founding
fathers and the framers
thomas goes even further he says
actually we should revisit these
questions
even if we want to have condoms and gay
sex and redefine marriage you might want
to do all of those things that's
that's neither here nor there
we just want to point out it's not in
the constitution it's not there no one
seriously believes that this radical
definition of marriage that it hasn't
existed
beyond five minutes ago that that was
present in the constitution in the 1780s
and 90s we just we just know it's not
there
show me the invisible ink i haven't been
able to see it yet so she makes that
there's a little bit of a digression she
makes all these points if you read the
liberal dissent
there's really no argument there the
liberal descent
the the nearest thing to a legal
argument is that
it is that because of starry decisis
because of the principle that
that rulings and precedence should just
persist even if they weren't argued all
that all that convincingly that was
pretty much it and the the second part
of the dissent is that if you get rid of
of roe v wade you're going to get rid of
all these other things that liberals
like but they didn't really make
arguments from the constitution they
didn't really make any argument that roe
was rightly decided because no one
thinks roe was rightly decided frankly
ruth bader ginsburg thought that the the
logic of the roe versus white decision
was ridiculous
she liked the outcome of the decision
but she didn't she didn't agree with the
legal argument so aoc babbling babbling
babbling and then there's the cherry on
top which is she says that the justices
lied you're going to hear this so much
from the left over the next few days
barrett and kavanaugh and gorsuch and
alito they lied before congress before
the senate
when they were being confirmed why
because they said
that roe was precedent that roe was
settled law here's the here is exactly
what the justices said alito
roe v wade is an important president of
the supreme court gorsuch that's the law
of the land i accept the law of the land
kavanaugh it's settled as a president of
the supreme court barrett roe v wade
clearly held that the constitution
protected a woman's right to terminate a
pregnancy
aoc says those are lies because they
voted to overrule it
not a single word there is a lie
alito gorsuch kavanaugh they didn't say
anything that that wasn't true
roe v wade was an important precedent
met by the supreme court
roe v wade was the law of the land
roe v wade did clearly hold that a woman
has a right to an abortion
that was all true
then
that is not true now
and it's not true because now we've got
a new precedent and i cannot wait for
the next well i can't wait i want to
wait a long time for the next liberal
supreme court justice
but once the next liberal supreme court
justice is selected and goes through the
confirmation process
i cannot wait for the republicans to
grill that justice
say all right justice so and so
justice ocasio-cortez all right all
right
potential future judge ocasio-cortez
do you accept that dobbs versus jackson
women's health organization is the law
of the land
and just wait to hear what they say
because probably what what the liberal
judge is going to have to do is the
exact sort of verbal tricks that the
conservative justices did it's not even
really a trick they're saying yes this
is precedent
everyone knows what that means
but now but now we've got a new
president now we've got a new law of the
land and it happens to be the correct
one so
once aoc makes these claims it's not
just her it's bidens all these people
are really really furious over the dobbs
decision
the democrats in congress decided to
take a break from investigating an
insurrection you know january january 6
the worst insurrection ever in history
they decided to take a break from that
to incite an insurrection aoc comes out
she says this is illegitimate and we
need to get into the streets
[Music]
both of those phrases
are calls to insurrection
she's saying illegitimate she's saying
the government is illegitimate
if that is not a pretext for an
insurrection i don't know what is and
then she says into the streets
if you had scripted this
and said hey what is the pithiest way to
call for an insurrection since we're all
talking about insurrections and that's
what you would say say the government is
illegitimate take to the streets
now i know aoc was supposed to be
investigating this insurrection but she
took a little break not just her maxine
waters who's always known for her
extremely dangerous red rhetoric she
comes out and she says we need to defy
the court
you see this turn out here
you ain't seen nothing yet
women are going to control their bodies
no matter how they try and stop us they
held with the supreme court we will defy
them women will be in control of their
bodies and if they think black women are
intimidated or afraid they got another
thought coming black women will be out
in droves we will be out by the
thousands we will be out by the millions
we are going to make sure we fight by
the right to control everybody thank you
to hell with the supreme court we will
defy them that's what maxine waters is
saying
on january 6 the worst day in history
there were
activists who said
they didn't even say the hell with
congress we will define them they said
we are going to
uh challenge the the electoral count
because of the weird way in which this
election was conducted and then you know
and then obviously some people got
excited and they went into the capital
and some of them broke in and some of
them were let in by the police and some
were just followed in and it was
it was a strange situation
maxine waters is going further than
those people did maxine waters is saying
we will defy
a co-equal branch of government
to hell with the equal branch of
government it's not legitimate we're
going to go we're going to defy them
we're going to take
to the streets sounds sort of like an
insurrection
to me
i'm so glad you like that clip now
you got to subscribe you got to ring you
got to get those notifications
this has been the absolute greatest
month
for the judiciary for the constitution
for american politics in a very very
long time make sure you get the
notifications don't miss a thing we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]